so this is so funny guys i just met to a
couple from chicago and how long have
you guys been married 36 years
36 years and
how did you guys meet
we got hired at mcdonald's on the same
day oh that's so cute okay who made the
who made the first move
i did she did yeah i did and what advice
do you have to young people today to
have a long and happy marriage oh god
should i answer it yeah you should okay
um
it's easy for young people nowadays to
have their own careers
and be
old enough to and set in their ways to
get out when it gets rough
and it's since we had nothing and we
were nothing
we had to stay in we grew together and
it forced us to grow together because we
had nothing
so
what do you think why do you think
marriage rates are dropping like why
people just seem to be afraid of
marriage today what do you think that is
my 30 year old is living with someone
and he's been living with her for about
six years now he's very anti-marriage
he's pro-kids but anti-marriage because
the perks of marriage are just less than
the perks of living together until
you realize insurance things like that
will give you the perks
do you think um part of it is like that
you know if a woman leaves the guy she
can like take a lot of his money do you
think that makes people what's happening
now with my
with my sister-in-law and brother
and it's a lot of fighting right now
going on because they were married for
five years and now it gets into
logistics and if you're not married you
don't have to fight for anything
you go your way and a lot of people that
each have careers so they don't have to
fight for anything
you just separate and you move on with
your lives and what do you think what is
your advice for a long and happy
marriage
happy wife happy life
listen to your wife